the British Prime Minister's closest
advisor Dominic Cummings has defied
calls to quit or apologise of
accusations he broke coronavirus
lockdown rules addressing a political
storm that engulfed Boris Johnson's
government Cummings also said he doesn't
regret his actions he says he acted
reasonably and within the law when he
drove 400 kilometers with his son and
wife who had covered 19 symptoms
Cummings feigned he went to his parents
property to insure his four-year-old
would be cared for if he too fell ill no
I don't I don't regret what I did as I
said I think reasonable people may well
disagree about how I thought about what
to do in you know in the in the in the
circumstances but I think that I think
that what I did was actually reasonable
in these in these circumstances the
rules made clear that if you're dealing
with small children then that could be
that can be exceptional circumstances
and I think that situation that I was in
was exceptional circumstances leave
Barca is following the story from London
for us Nev so Cummings confirmed he did
make this journey he gave some more
detail around exactly what happened but
but will this be the end of it do you
think I think
Dominic Cummings hopes it will be the
end of it most certainly Boris Johnson
and the rest of the government will hope
this will be the end of it there are
still some questions to be answered as
to why it took quite so long for Dominic
Cummings to come forward and give this
statement given them there's been a
whirlwind of scandal over the past few
days that is really denting not only
Cummings his reputation that was already
quite divisive anyway but also the
reputation of his boss the Prime
Minister not to mention the government
at largest as well why did he remain in
the background when he could have
cleared up some of the most pressing
questions much earlier than then he has
done also questions as to why Cummings
didn't let the Prime Minister know that
he intended to travel hundreds of
kilometres to the northeast of England
when he did just beforehand
that was not especially clarified coming
said that he could have made that a bit
clearer to the prime minister but given
that the Prime Minister's time was so
precious in the midst of this crisis and
as we know Boris Johnson was suffering
from symptoms of Co V 19 as well
Cummings implied that he had to make
that decision on his own there are of
course some questions about whether or
not this was the moral and ethical thing
to do given that Cummings was behind the
main message that given that was given
to the country to stay at home and save
lives
Cummings appears to have interpreted
some wiggle room in the rules and the
regulations and perhaps in the past few
days some have already started a
question whether or not they indeed
should be following the rules and
regulations set by the government so
most certainly this has dented
reputations it's most certainly
undermine the government's main message
and its instructions going forward and
could then leave Barker across
developments from London to talk a
little bit more about all of this when
Bennett is the political journalist in
the UK he is also there in London thank
for your time Owen what do you make of
what Dominic Cummings had to say today I
think what Dom Cummings tried to do
today was appeal to the public's
emotions talk about himself being a
concerned father and husband the
reputation that he's got in in the UK
among C lecturers are being a bit of a
bruiser quite a divisive figure as your
correspondent just said and so on who
you know prefers of swear words to
putting his arm around people and I
think you try to show a different side
of himself to say today and he tried to
appeal to people who perhaps have been
in situation he found himself in but by
doing that why say he found himself in
exceptional circumstances there'll be
many people who found themselves in
exactly the same circumstances or very
similar who did not do what he did
because they didn't feel they were able
to under the lockdown rules already
might have done actually is just further
highlighted that what he did was so
different to what many other people did
do you think he will have convinced his
critics I was also interested to see
some of the journalists sort of jumping
on the fact that he he has this property
available to him that has
three houses on it that he's able to go
for a walk in the woods you know without
leaving that property and that was kind
of highlighted as the fact that you know
not a lot of people do have that
available to them absolutely I think
that the reason why this is so
interesting is because they're one of
the ways that conservatives won the
election late last year was because
they've got a lot of people who never
very conservative before to vote for
them because they tried to they pitch
themselves saying look we can represent
you now we can represent you old labor
voters we're not like the Tories of old
even though you know Boris Johnson of
course you know eat an educated guy they
tried to tap into that kind of populism
that we saw around the brexit player and
what this does this just highlights to a
lot of people or we may make some room
feel rather that actually is one rule
for them and then being people who go to
Eton and then being people who have
three cottages on a you know state in
the country up north of a kind of state
making a state so it may just help
reinforce some of those stereotypes
which they've actually tried quite hard
to to minimize in the election last year
we are waiting for Boris Johnson to
address the issue again he's giving a
briefing right now about the situation
with coronavirus I'm interested what if
any damage do you think this is done to
Boris Johnson I think this has done a
large amount of damage to Boris Johnson
because ultimately he's the one it sort
of a real saying coming is he going to
resign as you're gonna step down is he
gonna stay I will see the guy that can
make the decision for him is Boris
Johnson and Boris Johnson is sticking by
him and it now has stuck by him to the
point that even if he was to second now
which also he's not going to do even if
Tom Cummings was to resign today
tomorrow in a couple of days time which
I don't think he's gonna do the damage
has been done the narrative has already
been set in the minds of many people
now Tom Cummings will say but you know
this is just the media saying this and
actually real people don't think what
the media thinks and look at the brexit
result look at the result of the 2019
general election to see that but I think
the difference now is that with a lot of
stuff to do the EU that was kind of
quite arbitrary that was kind of quiet
arm's length this lockdown has been
in which the whole country has by and
large Adir - they've had experience of
it and to see someone break it I think
that actually that will manifest or has
manifested an anger amongst the populace
which Cummings I believe is wrong to
dismiss as conflicted by the media hmm
thank you very much your time there Owen
Bennett political journalist based in
the UK